why is it acceptable that 150 million
children will go to bed tonight with no
parent no adults in their lives why is
it acceptable that there will be
millions of women who will have children
that they don't want to bear how is it
acceptable that 90 million children
around the world have no education at
all you know I think we have to ask
ourselves the big questions because if
we don't ask ourselves the big question
who is going to you know there's such a
tendency to think well we'll let the
adults worry about it well we're the
adults now here we are we're at the
grown-ups table and we're sitting right
here and now it's time and there is
simply no excuse you know I'm here it
has been doing some some of some of the
conversations about the future of the
world's children I'd like to hear the
politician who makes the case for let's
leave all the children behind you know
forget best interests of the child oh no
we all say the right thing but the gap
between what we say and what we do as a
society is enormous so I think the
questions are to say why you know the
question is to say why is that
acceptable why is it acceptable that
politically we say we value children and
then behave as if we don't the latest
UNICEF report indicates that the u.s. is
in the bottom of all the development
countries in their treatment of children
in every category in the bottom
unacceptable you know I think we gotta
we ought to hold we got it we got it we
had a fine we got a we got a whole
people in power to account and then we
have to hold ourselves to account
because by being members of the media in
this culture we have enormous power so
it's not good enough to point the finger
we better do some reverse finger point
pointing us some belly navel gazing
ourselves
you